Trascrizione: Sandra Cavallo
Revisore: Marco Caresia
Vorrei chiudeste gli occhi. Ora.
Occhi chiusi. Un respiro.
Vorrei condurvi in un viaggio.
Un viaggio di nuove scoperte.
Immaginate di essere leggeri.
I vostri piedi si staccano dal pavimento.
State prendendo quota.
Ed ecco che iniziate a sorvolare
una terra bellissima, meravigliosa.
Ci sono montagne innevate.
Ci sono foreste verdissime.
Spiagge incontaminate.
In che paese potremmo essere?
Forse in Cina?
Iniziamo a perdere quota,
ci appoggiamo su questa terra
e scopriamo una terra pacifica,
dove non ci sono dittatori,
dove tutti possono votare
ed esprimersi liberamente.
Allora forse siamo in India?
No, non può essere.
Ci dicono che questa sia la più grande
potenza economica del mondo.
Continuiamo a volare,
a volare, a volare.
Ma è ovvio, siamo in America!
Torniamo a perdere quota,
ci appoggiamo
e scopriamo tantissime nazioni,
ciascuna con la propria cultura
con le proprie tradizioni,
e la propria lingua.
Allora dove potremmo essere?
Aprite gli occhi, perché siete arrivati.
Questa terra meravigliosa e pacifica
è l'Europa.
É grazie ad un'Europa unita e pacifica
che oggigiorno noi siamo più ricchi.
Siamo sicuramente in una posizione
tale da vivere più a lungo
rispetto alle generazioni
che ci hanno preceduto.
Insomma l'Europa, e tutti noi di riflesso,
non siamo mai stati meglio.
Eppure, non sembriamo accorgercerne.
Neppure quando vediamo persone
disposte ad andare in guerra
pur di avvicinarsi a noi,
unirsi a noi.
Neppure quando vediamo persone
disposte a giocarsi la vita
per raggiungere
le nostre coste.
Insomma, stiamo diventando dei
pessimisti cronici,
quando si tratta di pensare
al nostro futuro insieme.
Alcuni paesi europei
si accusano a vicenda.
Altri vorrebbero addirittura
andarsene.
Insomma è un po' come se
non ci fossero più dei buoni motivi
per stare insieme.
Per cortesia, non fraintendetemi.
L'Europa è tutto tranne che perfetta.
L'Europa è così complessa
che neppure gli addetti ai lavori
riescono a districarne le fondamenta.
Fondamentalmente,
quando si parla di Europa,
siamo un po' tutti
Euro-analfabeti.
Non è colpa nostra:
l'Europa è avvolta da leggende,
da miti, che non ci permettono
di capire come funzioni,
che cosa faccia per tutti noi.
Vorrei sfatare questi miti,
smentire queste leggende,
e lo farò uno ad uno,
per distinguere ciò che è vero
da ciò che è falso.
E possibilmente per offrivi
un altro sguardo su questa Europa.
Economicamente debole.
Poco democratica.
Tecnocratica.
Costosa.
E elitaria.
L'Europa emerge oggi
come il nuovo Leviatano,
nell'immaginario collettivo,
capro espiatorio di tutte le colpe
dello stato nazione.
Queste affermazioni in realtà
non superano la prova dei fatti.
Si dice che l'Europa
non sia democratica,
e in particolar modo che sia
meno democratica dei paesi
che la compongono,
a cominciare dall'Italia.
In realtà, studi e le mie stesse ricerche
dimostrano come l'Europa sia
perlomeno democratica
come i suoi singoli stati,
ed addirittura
offra maggiori opportunità
dei suoi singoli stati
per i cittadini di essere parte
del processo decisionale.
Chi decide in Europa?
Decidono i nostri governi.
I rappresentanti dei nostri governi.
Insieme ai parlamentari,
che noi stessi contribuiamo a eleggere,
ogni cinque anni.
Insomma, chi decide a Bruxelles
non è Bruxelles.
Sono i nostri rappresentanti.
Bruxelles non è un'entità terza.
Si dice che l'Europa sia costosa,
che il suo bilancio sia eccessivo
rispetto ai compiti
che le sono affidati.
Ebbene, se guardiamo
al bilancio dell'Unione Europea,
questo è pari all'1 per cento
della ricchezza che produce l'Europa.
Sapete qual è il bilancio
della Repubblica Italiana?
Intorno al 50 per cento
della sua ricchezza.
Parliamo poi di impiegati.
Il numero di impiegati
delle istituzioni europee
è equivalente al numero
degli impiegati che lavorano
nei comuni della Lombardia.
63.000 impiegati.
Con una differenza:
che gli impiegati lombardi
si occupano fondamentalmente
di poco più di un milione di cittadini
mentre quelli europei si occupano
di più di 500 milioni di cittadini.
Infine si dice dell'Europa - e questo
è il mito più difficile da sfatare -
che sia elitaria.
Pochi eletti beneficerebbero
di questa bella Europa.
E qui ci terrei a dimostrarvi
che non è vero,
tramite la mia storia.
Sono nato in Italia,
da una famiglia con poche
inclinazioni internazionali.
Ma ho avuto la possibilità
grazie all'Europa di studiare in Svizzera,
in Belgio, lavorare in Lussemburgo.
Oggi lavoro in Francia, vivo in Spagna,
e, proprio per dirvela tutta,
mia moglie è basca.
Le mie figlie sono un po' confuse,
non parlano ancora tanto bene.
Ma fondamentalmente l'Europa
ha dato una svolta alla mia vita.
Così come l'ha data a milioni
di cittadini europei.
E forse anche ad alcuni di voi.
Ed è per questo che soffro.
Soffro quando la vedo maltrattata
dai politici, che le addossano
tutte le colpe, e a volte
si appropriano dei suoi meriti.
Ed è per questo che soffro quando
la vedo falsificata dalla stampa
ed è per questo che soffro
quando la vedo mal compresa
dai suoi cittadini, inclusi i miei cari,
i miei amici, la mia famiglia stessa.
Sapete quanti di noi,
cittadini europei
decidono di lasciare il loro paese
per stabilirsi in un altro paese europeo?
Ebbene siamo il 3 per cento.
Il 3 per cento. So esattamente cosa
state pensando.
Ecco, vedi, siete i pochi eletti,
i privilegiati.
Questo tuttavia non è corretto.
Perché noi, il 3 per cento,
non siamo una casta,
non siamo particolarmente ricchi,
non siamo delle persone che vivono
lontano dalla vita reale,
siamo parte di quella realtà.
In realtà paghiamo le tasse,
votiamo,
a volte a sinistra,
a volte a destra,
a volte non votiamo,
esattamente come tutti gli altri.
Fondamentalmente noi, il 3 per cento,
siamo la punta di un iceberg.
La parte visibile
dell'esperienza di vita europea.
Ma sapete quanti cittadini europei
hanno famiglia, amici,
in un altro paese europeo?
Sapete quanti di loro trascorrono
del tempo in un altro paese europeo,
almeno una volta all'anno?
Ebbene, siamo al 50 per cento.
Siamo dunque noi
che viviamo quest'Europa.
Siamo noi che costruiamo
un'Europa.
Siamo noi e non loro,
che stiamo creando uno spazio
di vita, di vita nuovo e diverso.
Forse è anche il caso
di incominciare a sentirci
orgogliosi di questa Europa.
Ad un certo momento della vita
tutti studiamo,
cerchiamo un lavoro,
cerchiamo un compagno,
una compagna, un marito,
compriamo casa.
Riuscite a pensare se,
anziché fare tutte queste attività
in un paese, possiamo farle in 28,
e allo stesso tempo?
Questa è l'essenza dell'Europa.
La possibilità di realizzarci
in uno spazio geografico e mentale
più ampio rispetto a quello in cui
siamo nati. Questa è l'Europa.
L'Europa è adesso.
Ed è nostra.
L'Europa non è sempre stata
un catalizzatore di opportunità.
Di certo non lo è stata
per i nostri antenati,
per i nostri bisnonni e nonni,
per cui l'Europa è stata una barriera,
non un'opportunità.
Mio nonno, alla mia età,
viveva in Libia.
Vi è rimasto quasi vent'anni,
a combattere contro gli inglesi.
Quando è rientrato
si è trovato di fronte
all'occupazione tedesca,
prima di incontrare mia nonna.
Oggi, i miei migliori amici sono
i discendenti dei nemici di mio nonno.
E le mie figlie giocano
con i loro figli.
Tutto questo è avvenuto
in meno di tre generazioni.
Eppure, continuiamo a non vedere
l'Europa in questi termini.
E non vedere l'Europa oggi
significa perdere delle opportunità.
Non soltanto per noi,
ma anche per i nostri figli
e i figli dei nostri figli.
Insomma, fatemelo dire,
è un po' come vincere al lotto
e non riscuotere il montepremi.
Attenzione: di nuovo, non vi sto
dicendo di innamorarvi dell'Europa.
Ma già che ci siete magari
godete di quest'Europa.
Approfittate di quest'Europa.
Nel momento in cui
non siamo mai stati così
pacificamente interconnessi
a livello globale,
ci ostiniamo a guardare il mondo
dal nostro orticello.
Siamo ancorati allo stato-nazione.
Che si tratti dell'educazione,
che si tratti del mondo del lavoro,
della stampa, della politica,
siamo comunque e sempre
in una posizione che è nazionale.
Sapete che a forza di fare così
ci concentriamo sugli alberi
e perdiamo di vista la foresta?
É soltanto se saremo in grado
di ribaltare questa prospettiva,
che potremo iniziare a vedere l'Europa
come un'opportunità.
Divisi abbiamo massacrato l'Europa.
Insieme, l'abbiamo ricostruita.
Ora, è il momento di viverla.
Abbiamo il dovere morale,
noi abitanti della civiltà
più evoluta al mondo
di capire e trasmettere questo messaggio
e possibilmente di pensare
quotidianamente
al senso del nostro vivere insieme.
Per fare ciò, dobbiamo essere
in grado di scardinare
la mentalità dominante,
quella impostaci dai politici
dalla stampa, dai poteri forti,
perché in realtà non è soltanto
l'Europa che ci è stata nascosta.
C'è di più. È la nostra capacità di
essere artefici delle nostre esistenze.
Insieme abbiamo intrapreso un viaggio,
un viaggio alla scoperta
dell'Europa. E lo abbiamo fatto
con gli occhi chiusi.
Ora è tempo più che mai
di aprire i nostri occhi.
Grazie.
(Applausi)